ذكرنا قبل قليل بانها ليست المره الاولى
التي يتم فيها استهداف الاكراد وان كان
هذا الشخص بالذات بالذات عذرا لم يستهدف
الاكراد في المره السابقه انما استهدف
اللاجئين بالصوره عامه ولكن عمليه استهداف
الاكراد الى اي حد تعطينا فكره الا انهم
بالفعل يشعرون بالتهديد همم في فرنسا
بانهم مهددون في فرنسا همم لم يكن واضحا
الى هذا الحد لان الحوادث السابقه كانت
محدوده جدا وكان لها سياسي متوتر في
المنطقه العربيه خصوصا الاحداث في سوريا
والعراق والتوترات مع تركيا واحد العمال
الكردستاني لذلك كان لديها سياق
لحدوث مثل هذا النوع من الاعتداءات على
الاكراد لكن اليوم همم لا يوجد حقيقه
تهديد واضح للاكلات في فرنسا وايضا وزير
الداخليه اشار الى هذا الامر وقال انه
اشخاص همم
المرحب بهم في فرنسا وانه شخصيا يتضامن
معهم مع قبيتهم وخصوصا اليوم بعد هذا
الحادث قال ان همم الاكراد في فرنسا همم
اشخاص نحن نرحب بهم بشكل كبير ونحميهم همم
وانا لديهم ثقافه علاقات مع الجاريه
الكرديه في فرنسا حتى انا رئيس الايمان
والمايكرون وايضا
قبلهند كانوا دائما يلتقون مع الجاليات
الكرديه ومع ممثلين عنهم خلال همم كان
يحدث في سوريا وفي العراق من هجمات لتنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه ضدهم ضد مناطقم ايضا
خلال العمليات التركيه ضد المناطق التي
شمال سوريا وفي العراق